la milice en fait elle est issue du
service d'ordre légionnaire qui était
donc le service d'ordre de cette fameuse
légion française des combattants
au départ la milice elle n'est même pas
armées
mais c'est parce que ils veulent être
armé pour se défendre contre justement
les attentats de la résistance qu'ils
vont être poussés à se retrouver sous
uniforme allemand parce que comme laval
ne veut pas armer la milice pétain non
plus au départ les allemands non plus
mais il arrive darbar n'en arrive à
faire une sorte d'accord a passé un
accord avec les allemands qui arment la
milice ou une partie de la milice à la
france garde seulement de la milice
contre justement un engagement des
miliciens sur le front de l'est
du côté donc de te laver remarques et
d'envoyer l'engrenage il est à ce moment
là saisissant pour que cette milice
soient armés pour se défendre dans le
cadre d'une guerre franco-française
eh bien ça va aller jeter d'une certaine
manière dans cette croisade contre le
bolchévisme qui a évidemment un aspect
tout à fait logique et qui est tout à
fait cohérent avec l'engagement des
miliciens mais c'est c'est pas une force
dans le sens où en tout c'est même pas
trente mille personnes mais pas trente
mille personnes armées dans ses trente
mille personnes ya des sympathisants des
adhérents des groupuscule d'activistes
sont très peu nombreux c'est une poignée
ces quelques milliers
ils sont très redoutable dans la mesure
où ils connaissent le terrain
connaissent le pays
yg rester localité et donc c'est à
l'échelle des localités que la milice
fait beaucoup de dégâts
[Musique]